what's up everybody we just got some
news about when the first trailer will
come out for Captain Marvel real quick
the infinity war blu-ray giveaway winner
will be picked
tomorrow on Saturday so if you'd like
your chance to win don't forget to
subscribe like and comment below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero so there has been a leaked
memo from Good Morning America that says
the Captain Marvel trailer will premiere
Tuesday that is the 18th of September
brie Larson is scheduled to appear via
satellite to talk about the movie right
after it airs on the show and probably
Marvel or Good Morning America will leak
it online shortly after this seems to be
100% legit and it's following the same
schedule that Marvel usually follows
after the Entertainment Weekly photos
come out so based on previous
experiences with Marvel and
Entertainment Weekly usually the
trailers come out very shortly after so
right on schedule
so be sure to clear your calendars for
Tuesday morning if not I'll try to get
it up as soon as I can for you so you
can watch it and again I'll be picking a
winner for the infinity war blu-ray
giveaway tomorrow so be sure to
subscribe like and comment below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero so you can enter to win thank
you all so much for watching woof woof
[Music]